[Music]
we all know the place the magic mushroom
houses the tight white pants excuse me
and all the different attitudes are tea
parties frenemies worrywarts sometimes I
just feel blue krang's shade throwers
nosy so what's going on over there
and there's one thing they have in
common 100 good old dudes now for the
one finger push up one - except for one
high heels but what if they were more to
the story
two days ago I saw someone who looked
like us that's impossible
and they dropped this now what if they
were never alone
if there really are other Smurfs out
there we need to find them what if this
means the lost village is an alleged oh
now you're talking about maps and
mystery Smurfs what's going on in here
none of your business
nosey well alright
brainy sappy clumsy oh that's not even
convincing I don't do well in the
darkness I have enough trouble in the
daylight
I didn't think last village was gonna be
this hard to find whatever you do don't
eat all your rations I just write all my
Russians is this
we're not in smurf village anymore wow
wow wow wow
lost Smurfs village it's time to take a
road trip I'll be like Barbara oh
they'll be all like oh no I'll be like
honey that's what I call talking out of
your butt
we have to find the village before they
do
incoming
ah huh
we mean you no harm
we're looking for the lost oh I'm really
freaking out you guys Smurfs the lost
village oh um guys who are they